hey guys today's podcast three
highlights from a recent session for DS
you know for DS daily digital deep dive
at $12,000 one day consulting product at
vaynermedia I'm giving you a little bit
of a sneak peek into it here are the
three highlights from this episode make
sure you stay to the end a little bit of
an interesting request at the end you
got your perspective guys in this clip I
really talked about one woman one man
practitioner ship when you're building a
bigger business and client service like
a lot of people think that every client
wants Gary Vaynerchuk
the reality is they don't get that they
get vaynermedia and a lot of you
struggle with that this was probably the
best articulation of that I've ever done
this is gonna help a ton a ton of you
who have three four five seven nine
eleven person businesses this is similar
to probably on a much larger scale for
you when you started vaynermedia right
now I feel like my company is called my
magnet management but our clients
predominantly a CRO they want to work
with Patrick France Co not I'm at you
know that realistically we have a
company but their most of our clients
are coming to us wear them out because
they know me and they're assumption when
they come to work with us is that
they're going to be working with me and
we're now when we could change you need
to change that assumption and that's why
I assumed that when you started that
same thing happened I know it was larger
scale it didn't they all came because of
me and the first conversation was before
we started this call or before we start
this meeting you don't get me you're
hiring vaynermedia I'm here I'd like I
get like getting my hands dirty by the
way you want me we can have that
conversation I'm gonna charge you a
fuckload more and it's not it's not so
much as the the actual getting down and
doing that work I've hired people to do
that it's more that I think the access
they will they want to be able to call
me and be like Pat I'm kind of unhappy
about this and this and it's like
getting at a point now now we have
enough clients where I'm like I could
very much more eighty phone
charge charged more for the access the
eighty first person that comes in you
say you're buying a company not me by
the way a lot of our clients came in for
access with me for an additional two
thousand dollars a month you have a
Batphone to me okay when you you know
anytime somebody hits more demand than
they can supply it's time to raise the
price and you would do that as a
separate I keep [ __ ] super basic why me
you would do that as a separate charge
that okay here's what you're paying for
us that's one way I would do it is
that's one way to do it
puts a value on it a premium value on it
could could evolve into a highly highly
profitable consulting business for you
you could end up how much top-line
revenue you were doing I mean right now
yeah we're doing we have about 50
clients and we're doing about probably
about what you might realize understand
first wait what you might realize is
you're actually seeing business because
you're giving away the most valuable
thing away for free because you didn't
merchandise it properly Thanks
yeah you know I get it man like you know
what's funny like you know I think about
a lot of things obviously in like you
know I've basically been in business now
for 20 years and basically run the
business I've been in for 20 straight
years liquor store to vaynermedia and
have grown big businesses fast and it's
because there are things I believe in
and I think a lot of it has to do with
upfront expectations over communication
a lot of things like that
it's very eat like I prefer for you to
hit me up in like three months to be
like bro I thought it was great advice
it sucks I'm like what happened
well everyone said no I'm like yeah but
that's good and you be like why and I'd
be like well because you but depressed
because in the way you're doing it now
who's gonna really [ __ ] up your [ __ ]
people don't see that
people don't see the alternative yeah I
have a very funny feeling it's not out
it's gonna play out I think it's because
you haven't written dies des properly
you got to create a bigger premium of
your time thanks one of things that
really worked for me without realizing
it was people would reach out the CIA
and try to have me to speak in an
off-site and it would be like 150,000
bucks and then they would reach out to
vaynermedia in trying to work with us
and they realized they could get a
speech to the team for me along by
signing a five hundred eighty thousand
dollar scope and like oh that amortized
out nice
there was an under there I understood
there was a value to that that used to
kind of come for free you're in a micro
version of that if it's so tied in to
you
you gotta establish its value every time
I see a movie where like the mom tells
the daughter like you've got to show
that boy what you're worth you know I'm
always like that's exact thats good
[ __ ] business advice my hot take on
micro influencers is that it's micro
micro micro give me an alpha mom in a
suburb in Pittsburgh give me the
cheerleader that's the most popular in
her high school who have 4,000 followers
on Instagram I'll show you bigger
business results than somebody who has
300 thousand and is verified if you're
focusing in that Lane what's next is
micro micro influencers more micro
everybody then the way it is now if
you're asking me what's gonna happen
yeah everybody's in play and the
companies that figure out through
technology or frameworks will understand
that they I mean it's very cut not very
complicated if I told you that you could
and I don't have the way to do this yet
but we if we were partners the three of
us I'd be like alright here I am guys
I'm supposed to be some sort of wizard
here's what I'm gonna figure out we're
gonna have a hundred seventy seven
thousand freshmen this year share
content at scale micro micro how one
does that there's a lot of ways to think
about it but what I'm good at is
understand what's gonna happen a lot of
times if you're talking about humans and
influencer marketing ambassadors
whatever the next thing you asking me
the question I'm giving you that answer
I feel confident about micro micro
here's why if you have let's play
in perpetuity if AI and machine learning
is good enough to be able to run an
algorithm and find every single high
school senior incoming freshman and
everybody who graduated a year ago and
you can get to them and create a trade
where you'll get more sales out of them
than you have to give them you would do
that that's right
I believe the way to do it now is
hand-to-hand combat I think you should
hire 78 people in a country that allows
you to pay them 3 bucks an hour to reach
out to people one by one just like DNA
on Instagram and yep we do that but it
needs to be scaled the end that you need
to hire Nagas laugh at them oh you know
that people doing it felt like on the
other end the freshmen what do you think
is most effective to offer them I don't
know but I do have a lot of pieces first
of all I would ask them so I would ask
that question to here's what I want what
do you want you can get a lot of input
that way but you know there's a million
cliche things you know that right
you know whether its monetary or free
goods or money or perks or access or
something cool that they think is
currently cool there's a million things
to go there I think asking works but I
think if you make a strategy to hire a
hundred employees in Vietnam
to do this I think it would work I want
to do it I'm giving you advice that I'm
thinking about right now I've got three
full-time employees but they sit in New
York City they're not inexpensive and
I'm building a first party CRM by
pulling everybody out of Instagram
because I don't want to be at the mercy
but DMing every single person that
follows me that's verified or has a
hundred thousand followers and I'm
asking them fill out a first party data
form so that when I send an email to 74
thousand people that are legit as [ __ ]
on Instagram and ask them if they want a
sample of empathy wines and if they do I
expect to the post it on their story and
post it's going to work that's have your
people asked me to
that makes me happy that's amazing you
know so like and I think that honestly
it the reason I'm giving you the bicep
I'm giving you by Sam I'm gonna take I'm
gonna hire a hundred people in Vietnam
or in Bhagwan or something like maybe it
might it might it might it might become
my company I don't know you know to me
it's a very simple thing what part of
the world is the least expensive talent
that is the most good
so I'm gonna be using a tool that like
filters correct because you're gonna
like where I'm going with this
cuz I think the human part matters yeah
that's why do it my team reaches out and
I'm see feed on a DM and literally on my
flight from London yes sir I'm just
replying it look this isn't garyun and I
take the video I'm like it's me and I
got lucky to like you know that was me
like so so that matters yeah and like to
your point like me writing it still made
you think it wasn't me cuz as much as
I'll say that anytime I write it's me
it's not gonna go there and so then I
have to do the video you know so I think
that will work I know that will work
hand-to-hand combat at scale to create
more opportunity of the long tail that
you can amortize and make valuable is
the game scaling the unscalable is the
game it will work look balancing
listening to the market and holding your
convictions is probably the most
important execution any entrepreneur can
do I highly recommend that you listen to
this clip and get out of it what I think
is right
notion of listening yes yes we do
yep all the time yep one thing we have
heard yep is that some customers think
our presents are too hot
yep so we have whether it's through
slack all right you know MPs score yep
we put an abandon carton
why are you not 15 now and it's either
I'm broke in college yeah yep we're not
trying to be Walmart we have a really
awesome high quality high design
products and our value proposition is
just so much more but how would you
think about I I think you always have to
listen to your customers but your
customers are always gonna say that my
interview is what happens in my office
once a month Karen walks in Gary I need
mentorship veiners been amazing I've
been here three years I'm [ __ ] like
your this is great I love it here
I need mentorship like I feel like my
boss is kinda you know like I need
[ __ ] mentorship okay Karen I got you
you know I'm I'm running the company we
hire some great SVP or VP I'm like oh
[ __ ] Karen right I remember okay we're
gonna snap her over there year later
Karen Wilson Gary I'm being micromanaged
I don't have room to spread my wings
Johnny's amazing as a mint but but he's
not letting me [ __ ] do [ __ ] Karen
last year you told me you needed a
[ __ ] mentor customers do the same
[ __ ] see waiting our that I wouldn't
ignore them I wouldn't ignore them no no
listen listen listen and synthesize and
make decisions right like that's why
both listening to your customers to
develop product is right and also
whoever said if I listen to my customers
I would have made it faster horses right
they both can work it's big data people
love to talk about big data big data is
very cute what you do with the data is
what matters
I'm so pumped that you're listening it's
a big advantage what you to or just her
or however you guys roll what you do
with that information is the key you
could stay the course and keep your
brand affinity in the right place and
win you could lower your price and that
was exactly right it was a 10% swing
that totally
of course in your business you could
lower your price by 10% nothing
different happened and now you just
given up 10% margin and maybe even hurt
a little brand equity they've all worked
listening and then the beauty of
business business is talent your talent
in synthesizing here's my real question
how many I'll tell you what I do in
those scenarios how many of those people
have you called because I'll tell you
what I'm good at and I don't know you -
it's one thing to read it it's another
thing to hear it it would mean the world
to me if this podcast has brought you
any value whether you listen to one
podcast or 9,000 of them if you could
take a moment right now I know you're
busy and I am asking and you don't have
to do it but it would mean a lot to me
if you left a review of this podcast
whether it's one stars or five that's
irrelevant
a honest score and an honest couple
sentences about why this podcast brings
you value thank you
[Music]